Hola Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
France 24 en español en esta emisión nos
acompaña aura García Hong Kong ella es
escritora autora del libro El día que
aprendí que no sé amar y también de otro
libro mar de piedra junto a ella Vamos a
abordar la idea del amor romántico un
tema sobre el cual tiene muchísimo para
contarnos desde una perspectiva crítica
muy interesante ahora hace estallar este
concepto y nos echa la luz sobre temas
claves en nuestras vidas aura García
Junco Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en francés 24 en español
claro aquí un gusto de hablar de estos
temas ahora bueno para comenzar No
empecemos por lo principal como
definirías que es el amor romántico el
amor romántico es un conjunto de
convenciones culturales que tienen que
ver con Cómo creemos que tenemos que
relacionarnos en pareja que comprende
pues varias cosas no que el amor es para
siempre que el amor es una especie de
fuerza mística que el amor es entre dos
personas únicamente y tiene tiende a
pensarse como algo eterno no como este
amor que dura toda la vida y que si dura
menos es un fracaso entonces son como
las reglas no dichas de cómo nos
relacionamos pero que tenemos como
condicionadores desde que crecemos hasta
por la manera en la que se reflejan
estas relaciones en la cultura pop
Bueno de hecho ahora desde que nacemos
todo lo que aprendemos lo hacemos
mirando imitando verdad Hablar a caminar
a amar también qué es lo que aprendemos
en ese sentido
claro Bueno lo aprendemos desde muchas
Fuentes no para empezar en nuestro hogar
que es donde adquirimos los primeros
patrones de relaciones no siempre de la
mejor manera porque pues en nuestros
padres madres son seres tan falibles
como cualquier humano que hay pero
también desde muchos otros lugares no
por ejemplo las canciones pop que
tienden a replicar discursos de manera
muy a crítica porque se basan como en
las mismas genealogías Y por supuesto en
las producciones culturales como series
o películas suele haber esta típica
historia de amor que todo el mundo puede
reconocer no esta historia que asocia El
Amor verdadero con ciertas grandes actos
o con el amor verdadero como
este espacio único en el que sientes un
flechazo de Cupido y que es lo único que
hay pero bueno entonces lo aprendemos de
todas partes no por un lado de nuestros
padres de la gente a nuestro alrededor
luego en la escuela se refuerza esta
idea no en las clases pero sí en los
pasillos y luego lo vemos por todas
partes
ahora voy a citar ahora un fragmento de
tu libro no el día que aprendí que no
sabía amar ahí escribiste la Fantasía
del amor romántico lejos de ser la
eterna felicidad que se nos promete es
el origen de muchas de nuestras miserias
escribiste y está atravesada por
expectativas que conjugan contexto
cultural
político y también la historia personal
no podría desarrollar esta idea tan
interesante ahora
claro Pues dentro de estos lugares de
donde adquirimos los supuestos de cómo
debemos amar
lo que no nos dice nadie es que se
vuelven reglas reglas férreas que muchas
veces nos hacen un montón de daño porque
en el momento en que nos salimos un poco
de estas reglas que aprendemos y que
nadie nos dice que son de hecho reglas
empieza a ser muy doloroso no y el
problema es que la vida a menudo nos
propone que nos salgamos de estas reglas
porque son reglas que son una especie de
Gran ficción cultural no por un lado las
relaciones actualmente es muy difícil
que duren para siempre y eso nos hace
estar generando una situación constante
de sentir que estamos fracasando en el
amor lo que quiera que eso significa por
un lado no luego también el amor
romántico tiende a narrarse desde la
heterosexualidad y desde lo reproductivo
el amor romántico va hacia la
reproducción y que no puede o no quiere
reproducirse también está en un problema
luego también tiene como digamos que de
llegada el matrimonio quien no quiere
llegar al matrimonio o no llega al
matrimonio también siente que hay algo
que está mal se basa Por supuesto que en
la monogamia quien no quiere practicar
la monogamia también no entra dentro de
estos parámetros entonces conforme vamos
viendo situaciones muy reales y muy
cotidianas nos vamos dando cuenta de
cómo el amor romántico es mucho menos lo
sano de lo que parecería no y eso ya sin
hablar de lo que concierne a cuestiones
de género y cómo históricamente al menos
en el último siglo se ha condicionado un
montón a las mujeres para que sean una
especie de
subordinadas del amor romántico
especialmente dentro de las relaciones
heterosexuales
y cuáles son ahora las consecuencias más
dañinas del amor romántico
pues primero que nada este sentimiento
de fracaso del que hablaba antes creo
que eso es lo principal sentir como que
nunca estamos dando el ancho que hay
algo más a lo que hay que aspirar y que
cualquier cosa que no sea eso es fracaso
eso para mí es gravísimo porque pues si
sentimos que estamos fracasando eso
solamente replica estos ciclos de
frustración luego por otro lado también
puede llevar a una violencia machista
muy empecinada no por ejemplo en el caso
de esto que que mencionaba antes de las
mujeres condicionadas a servir al amor
romántico como único centro de la vida
tiene también como
resultado que muchas veces podamos ser
susceptibles de quedarnos en relaciones
muy violentas solo porque sentimos que
es lo que tenemos que hacer
esto y luego pues también sentir que
estamos obligados obligadas obligados a
hacer cosas que no queremos hacer por
ejemplo casarnos porque sentimos que esa
es el único manera de decir que estamos
realmente enamoradas o incluso casos un
poco más específicos como cuando por
ejemplo muere una parte de la pareja y
las personas involucradas sienten que
tienen que quedarse penando por ese esa
pérdida que sin duda es muy dura y muy
dolorosa Pero tiene que estar penando el
resto de sus vidas Porque el amor
verdadero es solo uno y eso es algo que
también te dice el amor romántico El
amor verdadero solo uno Si amas a
alguien más es que no amaste Esa primera
persona entonces creo que por todos
lados es un concepto que en realidad es
muy rasposo y no
no permite que te salgas de manera pues
lo sana de él no ahora algo muy
interesante ahora algo muy interesante
que planteas también y que haces es que
colocas al amor romántico en el contexto
del capitalismo verdad O sea el sistema
capitalista moldeando afectando aspectos
de nuestras vidas que quizás no somos
conscientes de verdad muchas veces de
eso
Sí y eso se nota especialmente en el
tema de la pareja como una especie de
isla
en esta pareja que tiene que ser súper
autogestiva que no tiene prácticamente
que basarse en ninguna clase de
comunidad y que está por encima de
cualquier otra relación No aquí no le ha
pasado que tiene un par de amigas que
empiezan a tener una relación y se
desaparecen para siempre porque ya sólo
se venden entre ellos no O que citas a
una amiga ya nunca puede llegar sin su
pareja esta idea de la pareja como este
entendo indisoluble que va por encima de
todas las demás relaciones es también
una manifestación del individualismo que
vivimos socialmente porque aunque se
trata de dos personas también se trata
como de esta manifestación de lo que es
individual porque no se mezcla con la lo
más comunitario eso por un lado no que
pues si estamos haciendo de la pareja
esta cosa súper individualista le
estamos exigiendo muchísimo a la otra
persona porque estamos tratando de
sacarle extraerle hasta la última gota
de las necesidades cotidianas a alguien
que sin duda no puede cumplirlas porque
pues es solo una persona y una persona
no lo es todo y no puede ser todo y es
muy frustrante Pues luego por otro lado
está el hecho de que en el contexto
actual en el que vivimos que hay un
montón de la idea de oferta y demanda
desborda los productos y abarca también
a las personas pues hay una parecería
infinita oferta de personas con las que
podemos salir no O sea desde la manera
en que las aplicaciones de Liga y para
conocer personas nos lo presentan se ve
muy bien esto porque pues son fotos y
fotos infinitas y por más que le des a
la derecha seguirá saliendo alguien más
y eso pues obviamente también cambia la
manera en la que nos relacionamos y la
manera en la que concibimos a las otras
personas más bien como un ente del otro
lado muy lejano de una pantalla y menos
como lo que son Realmente personas como
tú como yo no
hablabas ahora precisamente recién no de
las redes aplicaciones están
fundamentales y claves no en la vida
diaria de muchísimas personas Incluso en
este tema no en la búsqueda de pareja en
la búsqueda de amor cómo han afectado
los vínculos entre las personas la
utilización de las redes y también Cómo
afecta el modo de percibir a la otra
persona
pues para empezar importan muchísimo la
tecnología que utilicemos para
relacionarnos Porque si bien no lo es
todo si condiciona la manera en la que
estamos viendo a la otra persona no O
sea como ya decía si tienes la ilusión
de que es una especie de catálogo de
fotos más que una serie de personas que
están apareciendo en tu pantalla porque
la tecnología misma está diseñada para
que así parezca es más difícil que
encuentres la empatía que requiere
relacionarte de manera cuidadosa con una
persona porque de alguna forma la
aplicación te está incitando a desechar
no a dar palomita o dar Tacher desechar
o arropar Y entonces esto también puede
ser puede Conducir a una
insensibilización y a una serie de
conductas que tienen más que ver con tu
relación con emoticones que con personas
esto No necesariamente pasa pero si es
algo que la tecnología incentiva o sea
grande historias de amor han surgido de
las aplicaciones pero también hay esa
tendencia hacia empezar a pensar en la
otra persona como
de gente que tal vez sea humano pero no
tanto porque no le estoy viendo
directamente a los ojos y que además
Pues si esto no funciona hay 800
personas más no y bueno Y luego está
también el hecho de que nos relacionamos
a partir de una imagen no eso obliga
Crea una jerarquía mucho más fuerte
entre las personas que son consideradas
hegemónicamente guapas y las que no lo
son tanto no por temas muy complicados
que configuran el gusto en general
entonces pues por ahí también hay varias
cosas Hay un montón de racismo dentro de
estas aplicaciones hay un montón de
clasismo Hay un montón de elementos que
pueden ser muy perjudiciales en la
manera en la que empezamos a concebir
las relaciones también fuera de la
pantalla
Ahora nos quedan poco tiempo menos de un
minuto pero no quiero dejar de
realizarte la siguiente pregunta no
porque contrariamente a lo que quizás
muchas personas podrían creer las
complicaciones del amor romántico que
también describiste afectan también a
identidades disidentes no a la población
lgbt y q muchas veces reproducen ese
modo de vincularse que hay detrás para
vos quizás un intento Quizás por
normalizarse entre muchísimas comillas y
de ser aceptados y aceptadas en una
sociedad muchas veces hostil
Yo creo que es en parte de eso porque en
una sociedad hostil Claro que quieres o
hay una tendencia a creer ser más
homogéneo hacia aquellas cosas que son
aceptadas constitucionariamente pero
también está el hecho de que pues las
personas que pertenecemos alguna
disidencia sexual fuimos educadas en el
mismo mundo que Quienes no y al final
Por más que haya cosas que se van a
salir de la regla en una relación
homosexual
Pues porque lo por definición Es así
también hay muchas cosas que vamos a
acabar reproduciendo porque crecimos en
el mismo mundo escuchamos las mismas
canciones que nos pusieron las mismas
expectativas vimos las mismas películas
aura García Junco Muchísimas gracias por
este tiempo en Flash 24 en español
Muchas gracias gracias a ti nuevamente y
a nuestra audiencia como siempre sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en francés 24.com sigan
con nosotros
[Música]